الله
اكبر سبحانك اللهمك
اسمك وتعالى جدك ولا اله خير اعوذ بالله
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
حرمت عليكم امهاتكم وبناتكم واخواتكم
وعماتكم
وخالاتكم
وبنات الاخ وبنات الاخت وبنات الاخ وبنات
الاخت وامهاتكم
التي ارضعناكم واخو واتكم من الرضاعه
وامهات
نسائكم
وربائبكم
التي في حجوركم
من نسائكم
التي دخلتم بهن
فان لم تكونوا دخلتم بهن فلا جناح عليكم
وح علائل ابنائكم
الذين من اصلاكم
وان تجمعوا بين الاختين الا ما قد سلف ان
الله كان غفورا رحيما
والمحصنات من النساء
الا ما ملكت ايمانكم
كتاب الله عليكم
واحل لكم ما وراء ذلكم ان تبتغوا باموالكم
محصنين غير مسافحين
فما استمتعتم به منهن فاتوهن
اجورهن
فريضا
ولا جناح عليكم فيما تراضيتم
من بعد ولا جناح عليكم فيما تراضيتم به من
بعد الفريضه
ان الله كان عليما حكيما
ومن لم يستطع منكم قولا ان ينكح المحصنات
المؤمنات فمما ملكت ايمانكم
فمما ملكت ايمانكم
من فتياتكم المؤمنات
والله اعلم بايمانكم
بعضكم من بعض فانكحوهن
باذن اهلهن
واتوهن
اجورهن
بالمعروف
واتوهن
اجورهن
بالمعروف محصنات غير مسافحات
ولا متخذات اخدان
فاذا احصن فان اتين بفاحشه
فعليهن نصف ما على المحصنات من العذاب
ذلك لمن خشي العنه منكم
وان تصبروا خير لكم والله غفور رحيم
يريد الله ليبين لكم ويهديكم سنن الذين من
قبلكم ويتوب عليكم والله عليم حكيم
والله يريد ان يتوب عليكم ويريد الذين
يتبعون الشهوات ان تميلوا ميلا عظيما
يريد الله ان يخفف عنكم
وخلق الانسان
ضعيفا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
كثيرا طيبا مباركا
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تاكلوا اموالكم
بينكم بالباطل
لا تاكلوا اموالكم
بينكم بالباطل الا ان تكون تجاره عن تراض
منكم
ولا تقتلوا انفسكم
ان الله كان بكم رحيما
ومن يفعل ذلك عدوانا وظلما فسوف نصليه
نارا
وكان ذلك على الله يسيرا
ان تجتنبوا كبائر
ما تنهون عنه نكفر عنكم سيئاتكم
وندخلكم مدخلا كريما
ولا تتمنوا ما فضل الله به بعضكم على بعض
للرجال نصيب مما اكتسبوا وللنساء
نصيب
وللنساء
نصيب مما اكتسبن واسالوا الله من فضله ان
الله كان بكل شيء عليما
ولكل جعلنا موالي مما ترك الوالدان
والاقربون
والذين عقدت ايمانكم فاتوهم اجورهم
فاتوهم نصيبهم
والذين عقدت ايمان ايمانكم فاتوهم نصيبهم
ان الله كان على كل شيء شهيدا
الرجال قوامون على النساء
بما فضل الله بعضهم على بعض وبما انفقوا
من اموالهم
فالصالحات قانتات حافظات للغيب
بما حفظ الله
واللاتي تخافون نشوزهن
فعظوهن
واهجروهن
في المضاجع واضربوهن
فان اطعناكم فلا تبغوا عليهن سبيلا
ان الله كان عليا كبيرا
وان خفتم شقاق بينهما فابعثوا حكما من
اهله وحكما من اهلها
ان يريدا اصلاحا يوفق الله بينهما
ان الله كان عليما خبيرا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر الله
انا اجوره
‏no anno
[Silence]
ادم عبد الرزاق
قران
ادم رزاق عبد الرزاق
سوره القيامه
‏This is the only contestant that still
has to collect their prize and their
certificate
so if you this person or if you they are
let them that their certificate and
their pr with me ان شاء الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
ان شاء الله تعالى
سوره النساء
last
will
ان شاء الله
سوره النساء
andake
from topic and
a large amount large portion of this
chapter
focuses on the right of men and the
rights of wom
and there is a huge emphasis
‏and not
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم would ofite
at the of ma
خطبه جمعه صلى الله عليه
‏and all of the chapter
and all of the stipulated in the chapter
for the men and for the wom
is all a derivative
and all through the lens of this firstاء
يا ايها الناس او بي اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها
عليه السلام باجماع المفسرين
حواء
عليه
‏and he forth countless
and wom
and dispersed countless men and women
throughout the land.
‏So here we have the setup to this
chapter we have the creation of man Adam
and a derivative of Adam was
his wife and this is the structure
in a very
general way this is the structure of the
household this is the structure of the
dynamic between male and female
اللهى
[Silence]
‏and
الله
للذكر مثل حظ الانثيين
inheritance
‏equent
foremes
now there
isn't we couldale get two
of what a female gets or we could say a
female gets half of what a man gets a
male gets there two ways of saying the
same
‏in order
that this isue
purely with respect to mas andine purely
with andalees
the for theale
the ofemes
and
tells
20 years
over000 cases of marceing
what have you
I have been with people from the begin
of their mar to the end and if I to
su up all those cases
the ma of the household if we could them
‏would
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا تتمنوا ما فضل الله به بعضكم على بعض
للرجال نصيب مما اكتسبوا
وللنساء نصيب مما اكتسبن واسال الله من
فضله ان الله كان بكل شيء عليما
‏tells us do not wish
for what the otheres
for men
is what they earn and what is alled for
them and for women what they have earned
and what is alled for them with
and ask from bounty indeed is knowing of
all things
so he tell us don't even wish
‏Dicuse
99%
alls in the household either the wife
trying to be the husband or the husband
trying to be the wife.
‏andle
it everyon
and a neuton right i'm not aysic
f can break this down for us better but
just we have that on the smallest
scale
‏all
makes up
in temple
house of
that we are all toild here with one
another as a community
each gender
‏wife her and wife has her and is not to
compete with the man and his role and
this isn't just in husband and wife but
also in male and female
men are not wom they are supposed to be
as far away from that as possible and
women are not
‏wom you now they can't be females
pressured to be and women at the same
time has to beant and have and beemin
also has to go out into the world and
fight with wild animals over scraps and
then we expect them to be female and to
be st and to beem
‏and other
females have
they are not to be comp
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لعن الله المتشبهات من النساء بالرجال
ولعن الله المتشبهين من الرجال بالنساء
الله لعنه
‏upon aemale
imitates
and curse is upon men who imitate women
in anything in their dress in their walk
in their spe in their the way that
they carry themselves in all facet men
and women are very distinct and we need
to have those two distinctions otherwi
as a society we will regress
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمني وكرمه وجودا
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
وان يزيدنا علما والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد
الوقت ما بحرتش على الساعه
‏What are we going to do?
Yeah.
‏We try to catch
[Silence]
الله
يلا
[Silence]
بسم الله
استووا
[Silence]
الله اكبر اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
واعبدوا الله ولا تشركوا به شيئا
وبالوالدين
احسانا وبذي القربى واليتامى والمساكين
والجار ذي القربى
والجار ذي القربى والجار الجنب
والجار الجنب والصاحب بالجنب وابن السبيل
وما ملكت ايمانكم
ان الله لا يحب من كان مختالا فخورا
الذين يبخلون ويامرون
الناس بالبخل
واعتدنا للكافرين
عذابا
مهينا
الذين يبخلون ويامرون
الناس بالبخل ويكتمون ما اتاهم الله من
فضله
واعتدنا للكافرين
عذابا مهينا
والذين ينفقون اموالهم رئاء
الناس ولا يؤمنون بالله ولا باليوم الاخر
ومن يكن الشيطان له قرينا فساء
قرينا
وماذا عليهم لو امنوا بالله واليوم الاخر
وانفقوا مما رزقهم الله
وكان الله بهم عليما
ان الله لا يظلم مثقال ذره
وان تك حسنه يضاعفها
ويؤت من لدنه اجرا عظيما
فكيف اذا فكيف اذا فكيف اذا فكيف اذا جئنا
من كل امه
بشهيد
وجئنا بك على هؤلاء
شهيد دا يومئذ يود الذين كفروا وعصوا
الرسول لو تسوى بهم الارض لو تسوى بهم
الارض ولا يكتمون الله حديثا
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقربوا الصلاه
وانتم سكارى حتى تعلموا ما تقولون
ولا جنبا الا عابري سبيل حتى تغتسلوا
وان كنتم
مرضى او على سفر او جاء احد منكم من
الغائط
او لامستم النساء فلم تجدوا ماء
فتيمموا
فتيمم
موا صعيدا طيبا
فامسحوا بوجوهكم وايديكم ان الله كان عفوا
غفورا
الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من الكتاب
يشترون الضلاله ويريدون ان تضلوا السبيل
والله اعلم باعداء
كم وكفى بالله وليا وكفى بالله نصيرا
من الذين هادوا يحرفون الكلم عن مواضعه
ويقولون سمعنا وعصينا
ويقولون سمعنا وعصينا واسمع غير مسمع
وراعنا ليا بالسنتهم وطعن
في الدين
ولو انهم قالوا سمعنا واطعنا واسمع
وانظرنا لكان خيرا لهم واقوم ولكن لعنهم
الله
ولكن لعنهم الله بكفرهم فلا يؤمنون الا
قليلا
يا ايها الذين اوتوا الكتاب امنوا بما
نزلنا مصدقا لما معكم من قبل ان نطمس
وجوها
من قبل ان نطمس وجوها فنردها على ادبارها
او نلعنهم كما لعنا اصحاب السبت وكان امر
الله مفعولا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله لا يغفر ان يشرك به ويغفر ما دون
ذلك لمن يشاء
ومن يشرك بالله فقد افترى اثما عظيما
الم تر الى الذين يزكون انفسهم
بل الله يزكي من يشاء
ولا يظلمون فتيلا
انظر كيف يفترون على الله الكذب وكفى به
اثما مبينا
الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من الكتاب
يؤمنون بالجبت والطاغوت ويقولون للذين
كفروا
ويقولون للذين كفروا هؤلاء
اهدى من الذين امنوا سبيلا
اولئك
الذين لعنهم الله
ومن يلعن الله فلن تجد له نصيرا
ام لهم نصيب من الملك فاذا لا يؤتون الناس
نقيرا
ام يحسدون الناس على ما اتاهم الله من
فضله
فقد اتينا ال ابراهيم الكتاب والحكمه
واتيناهم
ملكا عظيما
فمنهم من امن به ومنهم من صد عنه
وكفى بجهنم
سعيرا
ان الذين كفروا سوف نصليهم نارا
ان الذين كفروا باياتنا سوف نصليهم نارا
نارا كلما نضجت جلودهم
بدلناهم جلودا غيرها ليذوقوا العذاب
ان الله كان عزيزا حكيما
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات سندخلهم
جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها ابدا
وازواج
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات سندخلهم
جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ابدا
لهم فيها ازواج مطه
وندخلهم ظلالي
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
ب
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله يامركم ان تؤدوا الامانات الى
اهلها
واذا حكمتم
بين
الناس ان تحكموا بالعدل
ان الله نعم ما يعظكم به ان الله كان
سميعا بصيرا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله واطيعوا
الرسول واولي الامر منكم
فان تنازعتم في شيء فردوه الى الله فردوه
الى الله والرسول ان كنتم
ان كنتم تؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر
ذلك خير
واحسن تاويلا
الم تر الى الذين يزعمون انهم امنوا بما
انزل اليك وما انزل من قبلك يريدون
يريدون ان يتحاكموا الى الطاغوت وقد امروا
ان يكفروا به ويريد الشيطان ان يضلهم
ضلالا بعيدا
واذا قيل لهم تعالوا الى ما انزل الله
والى الرسول رايت المنافقين
رايت المنافقين يصدون عنك صدودا
فكيف اذا اصابتهم مصيبه
بما قدمت ايديهم
ثم جاؤوك
يحلفون بالله ان اردنا الا احسانا وتوفيقا
اولئك اولئك
الذين يعلم الله ما في قلوبهم
فاعرض عنهم وعظهم وقل لهم في انفسهم قولا
بليغا
وما ارسلنا من رسول الا ليطاع باذن الله
ولو انهم اذ ظلموا انفسهم جاؤوك
فاستغفروا الله
جاؤوك
فاستغفروا الله واستغفر لهم الرسول لوجدوا
الله توابا رحيم علما
فلا وربك لا يؤمنون حتى يحكموك فيما شجر
بينهم
ثم لا يجدوا في انفسهم حرجا مما قضيت
ويسلموا
تسليما
ولو انا كتبنا عليهم ان اقتلوا انفسكم او
اخرجوا من دياركم ما فعلوه
ما فعلوه الا قليل
منهم
ولو انهم فعلوا ما يوعظون به لكان خيرا
لهم واشد تثبيتا
واذا لاتيناهم
من لدنا اجرا عظيما
ولها لديناهم صراطا مستقيما
ومن يطع الرسول ومن يطع الله والرسول
فاولئك
مع الذين انعم الله عليهم
مع الذين انعم الله عليهم من النبيين
والصديق قين والشهداء
والشهداء
والصالحين
وحسن اولئك
رفيقا
ذلك الفضل من الله وكفى بالله عليما
يا ايها الذين امنوا خذوا حذركم انفروا
ثبات او انفروا جميعا
وان منكم لمن ليطئن
فان اصابتكم
مصيبه
قال قد انعم الله علي اذ لم اكن
معهم شهيدا
ولئن اصابكم فضل من الله ليقولنك
لم تكن بينكم وبينه موده
يا ليتني كنت
معهم فافوز فوزا عظيما
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فلي يقاتل في سبيل الله الذين يشرون
الحياه الدنيا بالاخره
ومن يقاتل في سبيل الله فيقتل او يغرب
فسوف نؤتيه اجرا عظيما
وما لكم تقاتلون في سبيل الله والمستضعفين
من الرجال والنساء
والولدان الذين يقولون
الذين يقولون ربنا اخرجنا من هذه القريه
الظالم اهلها
واجعل لنا من لدنك وليا واجعل لنا من لدنك
نصيرا
الذين امنوا يقاتلون في سبيل الله
الذين كفروا يقاتلون في سبيل الطاغوت
فقاتلوا اولياء
الشيطان ان كيد الشيطان كان ضعيفا
الم تر الى الذين قيل لهم كفوا ايديكم
واقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه
فلما
كتب عليهم القتال اذا فريق منهم يخشون
الناس كخشيه الله
يخشون الناس كخشيه الله او اشد خشيه
وقالوا ربنا لم كتبت علينا القتال
لولا اخرتنا الى اجل قريب
قل متاع
الدنيا قليل والاخره خير لمن اتقى ولا
تظلمون فتيلا
اينما تكونوا يدرككم الموت ولو كنتم فيروج
مشيده
وان تصبهم سيئه
وان تصبهم حسنه يقولوا هذه من عند الله
وان تصبهم سيئه يقولوا هذه من عندك
قل كل من عند الله
فما لهؤلاء
القوم لا يكادون يفقهون حديثا
ما اصابك من حسنه فمن الله
وما اصابك من سيئات فمن نفسك
وارسلناك للناس رسولا وكفى بالله شهيدا
من يطع الرسول فقد اطاع الله
ومن تولى فما ارسلناك عليهم حفيظا
ويقول يقولون طاعه فاذا برزوا من عندك بيت
طائفه
منهم غير الذي تقول
والله يكتب ما يبيتون
فاعرض عنهم وتوكل على الله
وتوكل على الله وكفى بالله وكيلا
افلا يتدب
القران
ولو كان من عند غير لوجدوا فيه اختلافا
كثيرا
واذا جاءهم
امر من الامن او الخوف اذاعوا به ولو ردوه
الى الرسول والى اولي الامر منهم لعلمه
الذين يستنبطونه
منهم
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته لاتبعتم
الشيطان الا قليلا
فقاتل في سبيل الله لا تكلف الا نفسك وحرض
المؤمنين
عسى الله ان يكف باس الذين كفروا
والله اشد باسا
واشد تنكيلا
من يشفع شفاعه حسنه يكن له نصيب منها
ومن يشفع شفاعه
سيئه يكن له كفل منها
وكان الله على كل شيء مقيتا
واذا حييتم
بتحيه
فحيوا باحسن منها او ردوها
ان الله كان على كل شيء حسيبا
الله لا اله الا هو ليجمعنكم
الى يوم القيامه لا ريب فيه
ومن اصدق من الله
حديثا
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
لا